what are the three things that poor
people do that rich people don't do or
you can reverse it you have three things
rich people do that poor people don't do
well I I can tell you uh uh they they
have a the intuition of how they uh
judge people because everything is about
the whole intuition part right you're
sitting there who you choose to befriend
who you choose to have relationships
with you know and how you water those
relationships because if you want to
have a relationship together and it's
just take take nothing's going to happen
I remember I'm a 24 year old kid
uh I don't know nothing about business
I've done some stuff in sales but I
really don't know nothing about business
I'm I'm a 22 year old kid I go and I
take this guy I go to a job interview at
the advertising group shout out to Jamie
hepb and I watched this guy he
interviews me I'm I'm at that time
working at Morgan Stanley Dean with her
but I'm trying to see what else I want
to do okay so I got started day before 9
11 but I'm still interviewing I sit with
them in the interview and the way he
interviewed me I sat and I said I will
never work for this company because it's
just not what I want to do because they
were selling Xerox machines and uh
business to business I said but I want
to have a relationship with you I said
do you mind if I get your business card
he said yeah sure I said okay great so
it gives me his business card year and a
half later
I get a job I'm doing good at this point
I'm making some income 23 years old I
call them up and I said Jamie you don't
remember me but I want to take you out
to lunch and I want to pick your brain
if you don't mind I told you a year and
a half ago that I wanted to do this with
you you said yes he says great let's do
it so we go to Macaroni and Macaroni
Grill somewhere in Culver City right
around here like Victory Overland some
somewhere around that area
so we go there he brings this drop dead
gorgeous girl that works for him I think
her name is Natalia or Natasha or
something with Anne right and she's
beautiful short skirt perfect legs
Flawless beautiful face she's sitting
right there and I know what he's trying
to do he's trying to woo me to go be one
of his sales guys and I said look with
all due respect you're beautiful but I
have no interest in you my interest is
in you is it fair if we just talk
business for an hour he says yes so I
went okay now at this point he's making
a million I'm making 50 Grand here I'm a
nobody okay
we have lunch again I'm taking those
taking no sticky notes I offered to pay
he doesn't let me pay he pays he says I
got it no problem when I leave I send
him a book
we had this meeting that we did every
three to six months together at this
restaurant Argentinian restaurant called
bamboo which they had this beautiful uh
soup
every time we would have dinner with
them or we'd go to lunch I would always
send him a book
ten years later he says every time I
meet with Patrick a book is on its way
okay so I value the relationship I asked
them what do you need from me how can I
bring things to you years lady he gives
me one referral that one referral he
gave me helped me open up Florida if he
doesn't give me that referral that
Florida Office wouldn't have been opened
up right one contact opens up a whole
state Okay so
another relationship I can tell you
about is
I was going to churches and I said let
me see what's going to happen with these
churches and I'm going to churches and
I'm going to these different places I'm
having I'm studying Scientology I'm
studying LDS I'm studying Jehovah
Judaism I'm studying everything at this
point of the game I was obsessed with
religion so all I want to do is study
study study everything about religion
right and I'm 24 25. I eventually find
this church called Shepherd Shepherd of
the Hills which is ran by a guy named
Dudley Rutherford and I go to this place
and I'm I'm an atheist so it's not like
I'm going to I'm just trying to see
what's going on over here I'm just
trying to learn I'm not trying to do it
I go this place and I'm like okay I like
this guy's style you typically go to
church if you don't do this you don't
know hell anyhow dude I don't need to
know I'm going to hell I know I'm going
to hell I just want and I was shot in
heaven you know what I'm saying so this
guy's energy was you have a shot at
heaven right okay cool all right
I know the score let me see maybe I got
a shot over here so I go there and I'm
sitting in the back I watch them once
twice three times four times I'm like
wow I like this guy so then I sent him
an email a little bit of an arrogant
email but I'll tell you what the email
was I sent him an email I said listen my
name is Patrick Davis you don't know who
I am but I'm going to be somebody in the
world and I know you are somebody in the
world but I promise you if you give me
your time I will always bring value to
you it will not be waste your time okay
I'm not doing anything at that time at
25. I got a small little office
operation nothing crazy we go have a
lunch together at Black Angus Black
Angus off canogo or Topanga
we go to Black Angus we sit down we talk
after the meeting is over with us so
what can I do for you nothing there we
go out again what can I do for you
nothing there what can I do for you
nothing there eventually says something
happened when my son had more Park
basketball and I made a phone call to
the coach and I spoke to the guy and
Anonymous anonymously because I didn't
like the way this whole situation was
handled he probably doesn't even know
the story I know the people may know but
he may not even know the story so
um so I make the phone call
we get closer he marries my wife we
change our wedding to Friday it was set
up on Saturday to Friday so he can wet
us anyways in 2008 2009 2008 he
introduces me to Tom Ellsworth you know
I talked about Tom earlier he introduced
me to Tom okay and Tom comes okay in
2009 he introduced me to Matt sapala
Matt sapala and Sheena I got introduced
to 09 they just got promoted this last
week at West Palm Beach to the chief
distribution officer PHP right he is now
the CDO okay we've paid him in the first
six months to do over a million dollars
they're they're doing very good at what
they're doing the business here but if I
don't have that contact and I water him
what his needs are not what I can take
if I give the needs you I don't have
those contacts so I think too many times
when you know you build a relationship
with somebody it's immediately what can
I do you know uh what can I and by the
way what can I get from yeah and I
remember how you were the first time we
met you know when we were done you and I
went to Earth Cafe with Jen and I think
even when I looked at some furniture and
there was like a Google shop that we
went through I don't know if you
remember that right across from Earth
Cafe and and you said Pat how can I help
you what do you need from me you know
what can I do for you it was on the
corner exactly exactly so we walked
around babe she said yeah I really like
this newest guy I don't like this
approach how he is that's the dynamic
That You Don't See behind closers people
may see school of greatness people may
see the books but behind closed doors
the context is about what can I do for
you so you ask three things I'd say the
biggest one is figure out ways to
strengthen relationships and take him
deeper because you never know just like
everybody thinks you're you know one
sail away or one opportunity away your
one contact away from your life changing
if you start valuing your contact like a
book of business yeah Everything Changes
that's true what I heard you say there
was intuition study and relationships
sure yeah does that cover those kind of
three things and I think when you think
about people that aren't making the
money that they want and don't have a
rich life whether that be quality of
life they probably aren't Discerning
their decisions and being intuitive
about who they should spend time with
they aren't researching more ideas and
expanding their mind and they aren't
giving in those relationships
yeah I would agree with that and I think
sometimes it's also not knowing what
something could lead into you know guy
one time came into Morgan said he's been
with her in a Harley-Davidson uh bike
and he had tattoos and he looked rough
very rough no advisor would take him he
says I'm looking for an advisor no
advisor would take this guy
yeah I need an advisor and like oh
there's a bank downstairs financial
advisor financial advisor Morgan Stanley
Deanwood or Glendale no one wants to
take this guy this guy's got no money
yeah so the guy comes out he sees he
says I'll just give them to somebody
else I'm good the guy in the corner
office that has a couple hundred million
dollars under management he leaves
then the new guy takes him then a guy
comes have 50 million dollars to invest
he got an in
herent count was 50 changes his life
change his life yeah and he put the 50
in the rookie broker got a 50 million
dollar money on their management you're
getting one or two points on that life
changing so for life for life every year
every year generational wealth we're not
talking about like a small thing here so
you can't just sit there and look at
relationships that you never know the
potential of a contact you have to know
every content could take you to some
place that you don't know it's like a
movie you don't know the next scene you
know so you can't just assume what that
contact's gonna lead into yeah sometimes
the smallest contact can lead into
something big
foreign
[Music]